welcome back to Pittsburgh it was a
question that gripped the world who
killed Tupac Shakur the 25 year old
rapper considered one of the most
influential artists of all time was
gunned down in Las Vegas in 1996 well on
Friday Dwayne Keith D Davis was indicted
on one count of murder was a deadly
weapon in relation to the killing DJ
vladder major commentator in the hip-hop
industry for years mentioned that police
in Las Vegas asked him to help their
investigation after he interviewed Keith
for his own show and DJ Vlad and he
joins me now pulled out a gun it looked
like he was reaching yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah
did you actually see a gun oh once
you got the region I got the talking so
someone from your car that's what I
started shooting
at Tupac and shook so Orlando
popped
they were drove on my side I was popping
you know what I'm saying but they was on
the other side right
well DJ Vlad joins me now thank you very
much indeed for joining the show
absolutely thanks for having me I know
you've studied this case uh for so long
and these interviews that you did uh
with keithy they've turned out to be
extremely significant in this
investigation leading in fact to him
being arrested and indicted when you
heard that news how did you feel
well I mean the goal wasn't really to
get anyone arrested it was really just
to get the truth of the matter uh the
story about Orlando Anderson killing
Tupac I've known since around 2007. so
this is was essentially at the worst
kept secret in LA everyone knew about it
but there were no arrests there was no
convictions there was no anything there
was no actual proofs there was a lot of
conspiracy theories around it so uh
around 2008 uh when I first heard the
Keefe confession tapes that Greg cating
got
um you know then I found out there was a
book that was about to come out I got a
hold of kefidi and his co-writer and we
scheduled an interview and we just went
from there
I mean it he appears to have incremented
himself in this interview so in the last
one
did you believe he was doing that as you
interviewed him
well I think that he believed that he
had a level of immunity when he did the
proper agreement uh I also I think at
the time he was saying that he had
cancer so maybe he didn't think he had
much time to live so he was just kind of
letting it loose at that point but
um you know it was it was a little bit
crazy that he actually sat down and we
did everything and when I asked him
about it sometimes he would try to dodge
certain questions but ultimately I used
the book as a blueprint so whenever a
question wouldn't get answered I said
well the book said X Y and Z and then at
that point he kind of went along with
the you know what was written in the
book
it's been reported that you have
resisted efforts by the police to hand
over all the unedited tapes uh is that
true and if so why
yeah it's true I mean ultimately people
that we have on our show
uh we we don't turn around and cooperate
against those same people with the
police uh for me just in terms of
business-wise and my ethics and so forth
I just feel there's something wrong uh
so when Las Vegas Police reached out to
me multiple times I just never responded
uh I think what they did ultimately want
was the raw footage that was an email
that they sent after a couple of phone
calls when unanswered
um ultimately if you know the style of
our footage
everything that we film gets released so
I think there's a little bit of a
barking up the wrong tree situation but
maybe they thought there was a gotcha on
there in the footage that was unreleased
which I'm not aware of it since
everything did get released But
ultimately we don't cooperate with the
police and you know we've had situations
where police have tried to get footage
from us and we've had our lawyers step
in and actually block it are you
concerned I mean you know I've done many
interviews including crime interviews
actually over the years there's always a
certain element of concern as an
interview when you stray into that kind
of territory about repercussions from
people involved I mean given there's now
been an indictment here are you worried
about repercussions against you
I don't worry about doing my job I've
been doing uh Vlad TV for 15 years now
we've covered a lot of very serious
issues we've interviewed
like Mass murderers like Sammy the bull
and and so forth uh so I don't really
worry when it comes to doing my job my
job supersedes any level of concern or
fear or anything else like that and
ultimately you know if I ever feel there
is a situation where
there might be some danger I always move
with armed security
you you famously a very big fan of of
two packs there's of course millions of
people were and it remained one of the
great mysteries about this if it turns
out that your interviews have helped
lead to solving this mystery will you
feel a sense of uh closure for Tupac and
his family
well I mean for me the closure came four
years ago when I did the interview uh
there was a lot of conspiracy theories
when it comes to Tupac there was that
you know Suge had him set up there was
the government did it there was the
first responder had a body that he
switched the Tupac is living in Cuba
somewhere there's there's a lot of crazy
theories out there so for me when I did
the interview four years ago and we went
through the entire story you know really
key for these entire life story but
really leading up to what happened from
Orlando getting jumped at the mall to
you know the next few steps to them
going to Vegas to what happened you know
during the fight to what happened
afterwards uh that essentially
told the story you know I've been saying
for years that I solved I saw the Tupac
murder uh you know when it comes to the
family I've had various family members
uh reach out through people to say
they're very happy about it but the
thing about it is um
you know I know people that were very
close to Tupac's mother affini Shakur
and they all told me that while she was
alive she did not care about the police
solving this case uh the Shakura family
had a very
you know
you know bad relationship with the
police we run out of time I'm pregnant
I'm really sorry I'd like to have done
more of this thank you very much for a
great interview I've been following you
for a long time and you're great at what
you do and I congratulate you on this
thank you very much
[Music]